let's go back in time
the year is 1876.
the united states is celebrating its
centennial
alexander graham bell placed what's
considered to be the first ever call
with his new invention
the telephone
the first kentucky derby race was run
one year prior
and at a farm not far from there in
central kentucky a chestnut-colored
thoroughbred horse with a diamond star
pattern and white markings on his legs
is born
[Music]
not long after as the story goes
a woman named annette swigert returned
home to kentucky from a shopping trip in
new york city
swigert's husband daniel watched as the
packages from her trip stacked toward
the sky were unloaded from the wagon
behind her carriage
seeing this he told her about the birth
of this new chestnut horse i've named
him for you the man told his wife
spendthrift
by the next year another horse was born
spencer's brother
annette told her husband daniel that the
new horse would be named for him
miser
on the racetrack miser didn't end up
amounting to much but within a few years
it was clear that spendthrift was a
champion and in 1879 he traveled to new
york and won the belmont stakes
when his racing career ended he was put
out to stud and became the great
grandfather of mano war one of the most
legendary horses of the 20th century
but spendthrift's own name has lived on
too as the namesake of one of the best
known and illustrious thoroughbred
breeding farms in america spendthrift
farm
[Music]
i'm michela tandera and this is
priceless
in this episode we're heading down to
the bluegrass state to share with you
the story of spendthrift farm and the
man behind it billionaire b wayne hughes
joining me for this is isabelle
bisquette who reported on the hughes
family for the forbes 400 ranking this
year hi michaela thanks for having me so
i'm here today to talk about the
business of thoroughbred horse breeding
and how we at forbes go about valuing a
horse farm like spent thrift
and we'll tell you about a new ruling
and lawsuit that may affect the value of
thoroughbreds in the years to come
[Music]
billionaires on our forbes list have
owned all kinds of horses over the years
that we've pegged values to
there's the dole fruit and vegetable
billionaire who's owned hundreds of
arabian horses and a campbell soup
heiress with a breeding operation for
horses that compete in show jumping and
dressage
but when you think of horse racing today
the kentucky derby the breeders cup the
belmont stakes
all of these races are run by one kind
of horse thoroughbreds
known for their athleticism and speed
this is a breed that people track so
closely that the family lines of true
thoroughbreds today can be traced back
to three what's known as founding horses
who lived in england in the 16 and 1700s
this lineage continues to be followed in
something called the american stud book
which is run by the jockey club a sort
of governing body for thoroughbred horse
racing and breeding in the u.s and
canada they have all sorts of rules
breeding practices specific colors and
even specific naming conventions that
owners have to follow if they want their
horses officially registered as
thoroughbreds okay but before we get too
in the weeds i think we need a bit of a
vocab lesson
because when you're talking about horses
there are stallions and weanlings and
broodmares and phillies and well
there's a whole nomenclature unique to
this world so isabel can you help me out
yep let's do it uh let's have a little
vocab lesson courtesy of the american
stud book
[Music]
okay so a stallion so that's a male
horse that is used to produce foals what
about a mare that is a female horse used
to produce foals okay so what's a full
so a foal is a young horse of either
sacs in the first year of its life okay
and there's a bit of a twist here right
yeah so foals can either be sucklings or
weanlings sucklings mean they're still
nursing and weanlings have finished
nursing uh but we will not get into that
much detail here okay so that's good to
know how about a philly so that's a
female horse that is four years old or
younger and a colt that's the male
version of a philly so a male horse
that's four years old or younger okay
thank you so much for that
uh and so there are even more types of
horses that we could get into here based
on their age and development but these
are the main ones our listeners need to
know for this show
so full disclosure we want to share with
listeners that while we were reporting
this episode ewan hughes the billionaire
who purchased spenther farm in 2004 died
at the age of 87.
spendthrift announced his death on
twitter in august this year saying that
he passed away peacefully at the farm
with his family by his side
he joined the forbes 400 rankings in
1996 but it wasn't his horse farm that
put him on forbes radar to begin with
that's right if you've driven on a
highway in the united states at some
point over the last 50 years you've
probably passed by the things he
originally built his fortune from
self storage facilities
yep he was the co-founder of public
storage which you'll probably recognize
as those big boxy buildings with the
bright orange doors that you can often
see located just off some highway exits
outside cities back in 1972 b wayne
hughes made a 50 000 investment to start
that company in california it's now
publicly traded and brings in about 3.6
billion dollars in annual sales but at
the time of his death he actually owned
less than one percent of public storage
stock
years earlier he transferred much of his
stake in the company to his daughter
tammy and his son b wayne hughes jr who
now both appear on our billionaires list
more of his fortune was made up of a
stake in a publicly traded reit he
founded called american homes for rent
and investments like his thoroughbred
operation while spendthrift declined to
comment there are indications that
hughes transferred ownership of the farm
to his daughter tammy and son-in-law her
husband eric and so to determine the
value of the farm it's not as simple as
tallying up the latest share count in
public storage
there are a lot of pieces to this puzzle
there's the land on the main farm in
kentucky and the horses who live there
there's also an operation in australia
too
and we have to solve for each part a bit
differently but with the help of some
equine experts we'll show you how for
the forbs 400 ranking this year we put a
number on all the main parts of the farm
and figured out how much spent through
farm is worth
so let's get back to the stallions
to help us figure out how much these
stallions are worth we called several
experts in the equine industry i
describe myself as a stock broker and a
real estate agent for horses i also
should mention i'm a bit of a therapist
at times that's chad schumer he's the
founder of schumer bloodstock agency out
of louisville kentucky our primary focus
is buying and selling thoroughbred
racehorses and breeding stock along with
that
we do insurance on thoroughbreds and we
do appraisals for banks
pretty much if it has to do
with dollars cents and thoroughbreds we
do that and that's peter bradley the
owner of bradley thoroughbreds based in
lexington kentucky okay so spendthrift
currently advertises that it has about
two dozen stallions on the farm in
kentucky it's pretty easy to find out
which stallions a stud farm has since
their names are on their website
why
they are looking for customers to pay to
have a stallion breed with their mare so
spendthrift in fact has this lovely
catalog of their stallion roster that's
sort of like a glorified bumble or
tinder page for each of their stallions
they have really nice photos a qr code
you can use to look at a video of the
horse walking
its pedigree
list of its races and awards
i like this quote from someone in the
industry on one of their horse's
profiles it says one of the best
yearlings i saw in 2015 he's lebron
james so along with that we can see that
each horse has a price listed with him
called a stud fee a stud fee is the
price paid by the owner of a mare to the
owner of a stallion for the right to
breed the female animal with a male
animal spendthrift has horses advertised
on their upcoming 2022 roster for stead
fees ranging from 5 000
all the way up to 250 thousand dollars
that's for a stallion named into
mischief
peter says that typically the owner of a
mayor will contact a stud farm like
spencer if to tell them that they'd like
to breed with the stallion basically
you go to the farm you ask to buy a
season at a set price and the farm will
accept the mayor send you a contract for
that year's breeding which you will sign
off on
and then you get to breed your mirror
stud fees can change over time going up
or down depending on how a stallion's
children or progeny do once their own
recent careers start for example a 2013
article in the lexington herald leader
reported that into mischief got off to a
quote tepid start in the stud barn
his stud fee in 2012 when he was a
seven-year-old was 7 500 and jumped to
20 000
the next year as some of his progeny
began to win important races
by 2021 as a 16 year old horse into
mischief stud fee had gone all the way
up to 225 000
which was the highest advertised stud
fee of the year in north america
when spendthrift announced its 2022 stud
fees the farm bumped into mischief's fee
up once again to 250 thousand dollars
it gets that high because the horse
produces extremely good horses through
his falls
and so the demand goes up because
the
buying public will spend more on those
yearlings and
as his yearling price goes up usually
the stud fee follows suit and so the
very general rule of thumb for valuing a
stallion is taking its stud fee and
multiplying it by 300 or 400 times
that equation assumes the horse will
book that is mate with 100 mares per
year over three to four years however
some stallions like into mischief who
covered 214 mares during the 2021
breeding season and 248 during the 2020
breeding season book many more than that
in a year which drives up revenue for
the farm and increases their own value
in turn
to refine our methodology chad suggested
that we factor in the exact ages of each
stallion on the roster and the number of
mares they covered during the most
recent breeding season i advised isabel
and i advise anyone doing that to not
take a hundred percent of the number
because obviously all the mayors aren't
going to be pregnant some are going to
die some are going to be barren some
will not have wildfowl so i think a
reasonable estimate is 80 to 85 percent
of the number of mares bred
and and the cover
cover fee and that's the income for one
year now a young horse eight nine ten
eleven years old
he could be worth four or five years
worth of income as a horse gets older i
would change that number to two or three
but you're buying an asset and you're
like any business you're looking for a
rate of return
and i think the stallions you know
typically you you want to make sure
a good investment in a stallion would
have you out in four or five years based
on this method and using the 2021 stud
fees when we did our reporting over the
summer for our 2021 forbes 400 issue
we estimated that into mischief alone
was worth about
135 million dollars
for the rest of the stallions we applied
a similar methodology where we estimated
that each of those stallions could be
worth between about five hundred
thousand dollars and forty million
dollars which is about what we estimated
for authentic the horse that is one of
into mischief's offspring and also
well
just listen
here long authentic is dragging in tis
the law all up to get by
authentic has won the kentucky derby
you know there is such an attrition rate
with stallions it all sounds like it's
just printing gold bars but it's not
yeah peter bradley said that roughly 10
to 30 percent of all stallions that go
to stud actually make it
there's a very polarized market here for
the stallions you know it's either
chicken or feathers and in fact there is
actually this new rule from the jockey
club last year that may impact
spendthrift and other farms in their
ability to as peter said print gold bars
in may 2020 the jockey club announced
that for stallions born in 2020 and
later those horses cannot cover or mate
with more than 140 mares per year in
north america
so while for some horses that doesn't
make too much of a difference that could
be a big revenue cut for some of the
most desirable stallions we reached out
to the jockey club to ask if they would
tell us more about why they decided to
create this new rule but they declined
to add more than what was in their
original statement which said the
purpose was to preserve the health of
the thoroughbred breed for the long term
chad schumer elaborated on it a bit more
for us the jockey club's mission is the
fostering nurturing and advancement of
the thoroughbred and in their opinion
limiting a stallion to 140 mares
provides greater genetic diversity going
forward i can't speak for the jockey
club but from what i've read and i
understand their studies are showing
that the current thoroughbred is more
inbred than it has ever been and so it
might not be a surprise to say that in
february of this year spendthrift and
two other farms filed a lawsuit against
the jockey club they're asking for the
rule to be repealed
the complaint filed in the lawsuit
states that as a result of this new
ruling quote the highest quality
thoroughbred horses will be bred less
times than market economics would
otherwise dictate
hundreds of millions of dollars of study
revenues will be impacted all owners of
mares will pay higher prices to breed
their mares and less well-connected
owners of mares will be precluded
entirely from access to high-quality
stallions
because this will only affect horses
born in 2020 and later bloodstock agents
like chad schumer are hesitant to
speculate on how this new ruling will
impact values of future thoroughbreds
those horses won't race in the classics
until
2023 they won't go to stud probably to
the earliest until 2024.
so
we won't really know how it affects
things for for a number of years one
could surmise that the fact that there
are fewer
opportunities to breed
would damage their value
conversely one could look at it as well
if they're going to breed fewer mares
they can have a higher stud fee so it
doesn't really change their value as of
publication the lawsuit is still ongoing
so we've got 135 million dollars for
into mischief
and for the rest of spendthrift
stallions we estimated over the summer
that they were worth about 165 million
dollars
so that gives us a total of roughly 300
million dollars
now
let's talk about the other horses on the
farm
yeah this is trickier because spent
thrift doesn't advertise rosters of the
rest of their thoroughbreds that is
mares foals and yearlings in the same
way they do with their stallions and
spencer declined to comment on any of
our estimates or to participate in the
story
so instead we look to the auctions to
get a handle on their inventory every
year there are sort of three big
organizations that run auctions for
thoroughbreds
keenland basic tipton and obs down in
florida
they each hold a number of auctions
throughout the year where farms come to
buy and sell their horses
as agent this is monument girl it's just
up there by tapazar out of drumette
five-year-old mayor
into the ring and she walked off the van
this morning here at facing tipton like
she hadn't even run
yesterday
this is from an auction at faisak tipton
last year where spent three purchased a
horse named monomoy girl for 9.5 million
dollars and she is that close to walking
into this ring undefeated
the one and only monomoy girl oh my
goodness right here waiting to get about
here what do you ask for one like her i
need to get there
let's get her started a million i bet a
bunch of people would do that one
million dollars bruce
not two how do you get a million dollars
bloodstock agent chad schumer attends
these events frequently for his clients
i'm going to give you a description of a
normal year not covered related because
i think that makes things obviously very
complicated so in a normal year the
horses are absolutely physically there
they're there for inspection sale in in
september for example would start on a
monday the horses would ship in the
thursday or friday prior to that people
would have all weekend long to look at
the horses sometimes they look two three
four five times even they get their vets
to go and check the horse with a scope
and read the x-rays a scope is a tube
that goes down the throat to make sure
it has a normal functioning airway which
is obviously very important if you can't
breathe you can't run very fast right so
that's an important component
but they are they are there on the
grounds people do attend you can bid
online you can bid on the phone with an
agent like myself you could bid yourself
whatever your whatever your preference
is most people have a team or advisors
or you know a system for what they're
doing a typical day at the auction for
me i'd be at the sale grounds by 7 30 in
the morning out in the barns by about 7
45 we work the barns until 10 o'clock
when the auction starts
and then it doesn't end until it ends no
breaks no lunch starts at 10 o'clock
sometimes it ends at four o'clock
sometimes it ends at seven o'clock at
night depends so it's a very very
difficult day and that happens
sometimes as many as 10 12 or 14
consecutive days all right i think he's
done nine five nine seven here we go and
i have
after an auction the results are
cataloged and published and so through
that sources we spoke with suggested
that we go back and piece together an
estimate for the number of horses that
spencer buys and sells each year as well
as the prices for each transaction we
found that over the last decade
spendthrift had purchased roughly 150
mares and phillies that is young female
horses that will one day become mayors
at the three auctions we mentioned and
in reviewing all their purchase prices
we found that the median amount spent
are spent on those horses was about 230
thousand dollars per animal that's
significantly higher compared to other
buyers in the industry
the median sale price for a mayor in
2020 was about 15 000
according to one industry trade
publication but in some cases
spendthrift is willing to pay much more
than that median dollar figure
as we mentioned just last year they
spent 9.5 million dollars on one mayor
named monomoy girl
and so keeping that in mind we came up
with an estimate for this bunch valuing
them all at about 50 million dollars
but then the other piece of our puzzle
is determining the value of the horses
that are actually born on the farm
spendthrift had said in an old marketing
video from 2020 that that year they had
about 85 foals and 50 yearlings living
on the farm
to estimate the value of those we again
turn to the auction catalogs to look and
see what spencer typically sells its own
young horses for which is about 37
thousand dollars per horse
we also notice in the auction records
that spendthrift was buying on average
seven colts every year and again we
noticed spendthrift was paying a lot
more for these colts they purchased at
auction compared to the ones they were
selling at auction their median purchase
price was about four hundred and fifty
thousand dollars
so figuring both these new purchased
colds and the value of the horses born
on the farm we estimated that the total
value of the group is about 10 million
dollars
okay so we have estimates of about 50
million dollars for the mayors and
phillies and about 10 million dollars
for the fulls yearlings and purchased
colts that's right but it's very
important to note here that these values
like stocks can really shift up or down
at a moment's notice and we're working
on estimates using as much information
as we can about these animals and
spencer's own buying and selling
practices
and as we can see from the climbing stud
fees on spendthrift's 2022 roster
i wouldn't be surprised if the value of
the farm goes up even further when we
review these figures again next year i
mean look it's again it's a very
optimism blue sky based business people
buy yearlings untried horses they have
no idea if they have the heart or will
to win races
they buy them on based on their pedigree
and their physical appearance and the
x-ray results imagine these yearlings as
if they were 13 14 or 15 year old kids
and you were and you were drafting them
for your basketball team
but by the time you were had them on the
court would be the year or later or even
two years later imagine how much they
would change physically you know but now
they're nba players
so in total we estimated that all of the
horses that were not stallions at
spencer were worth about 60 million
dollars making the total equine value
about 360 million dollars
but the other part of valuing spencer
farm is valuing the farm itself
it's land
in one way or another spenther farm has
occupied a piece of land in the heart of
horse country about 20 minutes from
downtown lexington kentucky for much of
the last century
and remember daniel swigert the guy who
named his horse spendthrift so in 1937
swigert's great-grandson a man named
leslie combs ii founded his own horse
farm and named it spent thrift after his
great-grandfather's prize-winning
stallion
over the next few decades he grew the
farm from roughly 100 acres to more than
2 000 and it eventually became the home
to two triple crown winners seattle slew
and affirmed and celebrities from around
the world came to visit like princess
margaret fred astaire and mgm executive
louis b mayer
leslie combs was one of the great
salesmen and horse traders of his time
he had a you know beautiful home on the
farm where he'd bring potential buyers
in and he would bring them in and let
the horses out in the paddock right in
front of his house and
the one that went to the front he would
say that's the one you need to buy mrs
green or whomever
and uh every day a different one would
go to the front and hopefully he had two
or three buyers for the better horses he
had lined up before the sale just from
his cocktail parties
in 1983 spenther farm had an initial
public offering but things pretty
quickly started to go downhill from
there
the farm faced lawsuit after lawsuit in
the 1980s from its investors and in 1989
the farm declared bankruptcy
eventually new owners bought it and in
2004 california billionaire b wayne
hughes came along and purchased the farm
for an undisclosed price
at its current size today it's made up
of more than 1 000 acres of lush
paddocks more than 60 miles of fences
with assortments of barns and training
facilities spread about the land that's
equivalent to about 750 football fields
the farm is located in kentucky's
fayette county so we turn to that
county's assessor to pull public land
records and get a sense of the value
the assessor prepares their own
valuations of every parcel in the county
taking into account what the land and
what any buildings on the land are worth
so i didn't realize this but the horses
actually eat the grass that they're
living on so while the farm isn't
growing a crop like soybeans or corn
it's important that the soil is good
enough to grow grass that the horses can
eat so for example just one parcel the
county lists its assessed value at 5.9
million dollars that's 330 acres which
includes the valley of the land plus
improvements which on this parcel
include horse stables a couple of run-in
shads which are like carports for horses
and a few mobile homes
if we add up the fair cash values of the
15 parcels that we found tied to spent
thrift we get a sum total of about 25
million dollars we should note that this
number may be low fayette county updates
its assessment every four years so most
recently uh on this farm they updated it
in 2018.
so normally to value land like this we
would look for comparable transactions
but horse farm sales in the area are
pretty rare we also checked for debt on
the property filed with the county but
didn't find any spencer farm also has
another operation in australia which
allows them to breed more horses during
the southern hemisphere's own distinct
breeding season
we estimated that the land and the
horses who live there are valued at
about 15 million dollars so there you
have it folks we've gone through the
horses and the land to show you how we
value spendthrift farm in total
we estimated that it was worth about
400 million dollars
not half bad for the family farm
[Music]
thanks for listening to priceless
this episode was reported by me michaela
tandera and isabelle bisquette
it was co-produced by me and jonathan
palmer with additional research by sue
radlauer
special thanks to the keenland library
for additional research